: pal have you gone back and thought
through the process of writing this book
and what worked and what didn't work
well it was perhaps one of those typical
things I've ever done in my life and
frankly it all sort of worked the book
came together there were some days I
wish I had never started it there were
some days I tried to figure out how to
get out of it but most days were
pleasant and in on balance it was it was
a good experience something good for me
to do really to get what was in me out
of me and onto paper what worked was the
collaboration with a great writer by the
name of Joseph Persico I could not have
done this book without him you say early
on the day he walked into your office
one day before he even left the Pentagon
and Bango you had a relationship we
signed the contract for the book in the
summer of 1993 about two months before I
retired and for the rest of that summer
period July in August I was looking for
a collaborator and I interviewed a
number of people I looked at a lot of
resumes a row I read a lot of books and
nothing really clicked for one reason or
another and so I started to get nervous
because it was now the toward the end of
September I'm getting ready to retire in
a few weeks I got to start this book and
I don't have a collaborator and day or
two before I retired I got a call from
my agent said what was this fellow named
Persico and he wants to come down and
see you and he's interesting he's
written the number of books as a
biographer he's never done an
autobiography as a collaborator but he
looks interesting
so I glanced through a couple of his
books rather quickly and the day before
I retired my secretary announces that
mr. Persico is here and into my office
walk this tall gangly white-haired
gentleman who looked like a as I say in
the book and the acknowledgments a
rumpled professor with a crushed strange
leather briefcase he is neither
impressive looking nor impressed by me
but he is an impressive man he just
doesn't feel it necessary to show his
impressive nature very at ease fellow
and he looked around my office and he
took it all in as a writer should and
then he looked at me and didn't seem to
be terribly impressed by me either we
sat down and chatted for a few moments
and I knew that I had my collaborator he
could handle me
he said interview that we did with him
that he had a hard time getting you to
give yeah he he made it clear at the
very beginning that if we were going to
have a good book I really had to go to
the depths of my heart and soul and
bring it all out we could shape it later
if I said some things or we wrote some
things that I couldn't live with at the
end of the day but we had to get the
whole story out and it took a while for
me to get comfortable doing that as a
Washington person as a general as a
military officer you learn to control
you learned it you know only show what
you have to to get the mission done
never never let all in your emotions
flood out you have to be in control and
that wouldn't work in a collaboration
like this and in writing a book like
this and Joe taught me that I had to let
it all come out and some days it took
some product particularly in the Vietnam
period where I was holding back a lot
more than I realized and and Joe helped
me bring it out why were you holding
back more than you realized
ah I'm not entirely sure except my two
tours in Vietnam were difficult tours I
lost a lot of friends in Vietnam it was
an experience that was not the most
pleasant experience for the United
States Armed Forces and we came out of
that war with a great deal of a large
number of problems that we had to deal
with we dealt with those problems but
all of us are carrying around some
Vietnam memories and I had suppressed a
lot of that and Joe Joe helped me bring
it all out when you went in 1962 first
time how many American soldiers were
there I arrived in Vietnam on Christmas
morning 1962 and I think they may have
been about 12,000 advisors give or take
a couple of thousand it was really the
second wave of advisers going in we were
replacing the first batch and we were
all bright-eyed bushy-tailed captains
and majors and lieutenant Colonel's and
we were there to save the world from
communism and if this is where it popped
up by gosh here's what we're going to do
it and we're going to help the
freedom-loving people of South Vietnam
from being overwhelmed by this red tide
it was more in that context than we were
getting ourselves involved in a war that
was fundamentally a nationalist war than
it was part of
a great contest with the evil empire but
we were ready together we were all 24 25
years old and this was the great
adventure of our young military careers
we went oh there were a lot of
enthusiasm what did you think of John
Kennedy then John Kennedy was a hero to
us all he was a young president he had
given us this sort of special mission of
counterinsurgency of dealing with this
kind of new form of warfare so it was
all very very exciting and you may
recall about that time we also had the
Cuban Missile Crisis in which he stood
down the Russians and this is coming
after the Bay of Pigs so we've sort of
gotten that one behind us and it was
very exciting heady time for a young
infantry captain who had been in the
Army all of four years when did you see
the first person killed in front of your
eyes it was a few a few weeks after I
arrived in Vietnam and I went up to
northern part of the country into the A
Shau Valley and on our first patrol out
oh I think a couple of days they are two
in they finally realized where we were
moving a calm realized we had time
realize the routes we were taking and
were able to get in front of us and
suddenly there was this burst of fire
and then we returned fire and a lot of
noise going back and forth and for the
first time in my life heard bullets
coming our way
with a distinctive crack and then it was
all over in a few seconds and I went
forward to hear to see what had happened
and I heard screaming and shouting and
the noisy confusion and there in the
creek bed lay lay this young Vietnamese
soldier who was dead and a couple of
others who was wounded and that was my
first experience you say in the book
that I'm not sure where you say this but
it may have been after this incident the
next day you wake up and there is an
exhilaration you're live yeah there it
was it was a quite an emotional moment
to be you know be in combat for the
first time and know that you know this
is no longer a game this is this is
deadly serious we know it's deadly
serious
but until you see somebody actually
killed it has a certain adventurous t'k
aspect to it but now
this is what it's going to be like every
day because the enemy knows where we are
and they can get in front of us every
morning and we're going to face this
every morning for as long as I'm out
here in the jungle with these guys and
so it was a bit of a shock and a bit of
a downer and we carried the wounded in
the body with us for a while until we
can get evacuation by a Vietnamese
helicopter and then we camp for the
night on the hillside and it all sort of
sunk in but then the next morning when I
woke up there was a sense of hey I'm
alive it's a new day sense of
exhilaration and also a sense of guilt
that I think everybody in combat goes
through you you have a certain sense of
the light that somebody else is dead and
you're not and now you got to try to get
to the next day without getting killed
and hopefully keeping your fellow
soldiers from getting killed as well by
doing your job as polishing could and
sure enough the next day we were
ambushed again in another book on this
program by William proc now about Neal
Shan and David Halberstam and Peter
Arnett early in the book he says at some
point this is the first time that John
Kennedy lied to us about Vietnam and
it's right about the same time 62 63 is
when all those reporters were over there
when did did you think that John Kennedy
ever lied to us on this no I not at that
time and remember he was killed before I
got home from from Vietnam
it's John your way back then yeah I was
on my way back at the end of that year
and I never didn't there was no going
home halfway through your tour at that
point I was there for a whole year had
to see my family or really heard much
coming from home but McNamara had said
we were able to bring the advisors some
of the advisors home early because we're
doing so well and I was one of those
advisers who came home a few weeks early
because we were doing so well and I said
to myself my god how could they have the
impression that we are doing well what
is it they are seeing that I did not see
as a captain here tromping these jungle
trails for the last better part of a
year and all
spending part of my time in Division
Headquarters after I was injured they're
seeing something quite different than
what I'm seeing they're conning somebody
and that's why I title that particular
chapter it'll take a half million men to
succeed because I remember telling
somebody that about the time McNamara
said let's bring some of the advisors
home early because we're doing so well
this advisor knew that we were not doing
well we could hardly ever find the enemy
we did not control the ground we claimed
to control and it would take a half
million men to succeed I thought and it
turned out that six or seven years later
we had a half a million men there and we
still didn't succeed your wife was where
during that first trip over there she's
in Birmingham Alabama living with her
her parents give any kids
she had one child while I was away my
son Michael was born while I was away
there's a story about you wanting to
know the minute that Michael was born
you just got that yeah this was the
early part of our involvement in Vietnam
so we didn't have our fancy
infrastructure that the American army
tends to take with it and so I was
essentially out in the jungle with no
way to communicate with anybody and and
I have written almond when the baby
comes on the outside of the letter
you're going to send me about this put
baby letter so that the radio operators
at our base camp would spot that letter
and they would have my permission to
open the letter and crank up the hand
crank radios we were using in those days
and give me the news and so she did that
but in typical army fashion the radio
operator didn't catch it and so I didn't
know my son had been born until a couple
of weeks later when I got a letter
finally from my mother which was dropped
out of an airplane flying over us in the
jungle and I opened up the letter and
it's this chatty letter for my mother
telling me about this onto that aunt and
how the rhododendrons are doing in the
backyard and at the very end of the
letter she said oh by the way we are
absolutely delighted about the baby what
baby and that's when I discovered that I
had become a father
and immediately cranked up the radio
called the base camp and they said I I
here's the letter and so I learned from
my mother several weeks after the fact
that my son Michael had been born C a
1963
old 1963 I was 26 years old 25 26 years
old you go back to Vietnam in 68 yes
what was that what was what was in your
head and what was your rank when you
went back I went back as a major the war
had grown in size we were close to our
peak strength at that time American
divisions were fighting all over the
country the war was not going well the
political situation back home had become
difficult it were domestic problems
associated with this we had seen the
death of Martin Luther King we seen the
death of Bobby Kennedy nation was in
something of an uproar and I was going
back to a war that did not look like it
was going well and this time went back
as a major with an American unit not not
as an advisor again and I became the
operations officer of the largest
division in Vietnam at that time Lee of
our caliber vision did you feel any
differently when you went back a second
time the enthusiasm wasn't the same I
mean that sense of adventure that sense
of I gosh we're going to save the world
from from this this horrible thing
called communism wasn't there we were
essentially in a war and we weren't sure
how we were going to get out of this war
we weren't sure that we were prepared to
make the investment that would be
required to either win or get out with
honor so I was a professional I was
prepared to do my job and I did my job
to the best of my ability as did all of
us who went over not only the
professionals but the draftee the
conscripts who were pulled out of
American society and sent over they
performed with great valor and we should
be very proud of what all of those of us
who went accomplished but it wasn't
clear we knew we were doing any longer
at that point in my judgment by the way
when you travel around the country on
your book tour and how long did it last
five weeks how many stops twenty-five
how did you travel from stop to stop we
had a private airplane took us around or
else we never would have been able to do
it and what was your did you put a limit
on what you would do on any given day we
tried to keep it to no more than two
signings a day
and these are not little trivial events
these were events that went on for two
three sometimes four hours where I would
sign two to four thousand books at
sitting so two of those a day Max and
then a number of radio interviews
television interviews print interviews
with the newspapers in each of the
communities and we tried not to have any
dinners or lunches or receptions we
really had to fly on to the next city or
get some rest so that my back and arm
we're up to the challenges of the next
day because at at the the size of the of
the crowds that were coming out we
really had to keep it moving so I was
dedicating 2.9 seconds roughly per book
per person and they would get a
signature that we get eye contact and I
almost always was able to say something
to each person who went through the line
and we averaged roughly 700 to 900
people an hour depending on the setup
how fast people could pass books to me
and what mood I was in that morning or
afternoon did you have a certain kind of
pen use I used the big fat Sharpie
principally because it gives you a nice
bold signature and it's nice and round
and soft with no edges and didn't cause
me any calluses and I could hold it
without having to grip too tightly and
it allowed me to have a smooth motion
other people use a bic or ballpoint pen
but I found a Sharpie to be useful and I
would go through about 10 or 15 sharpies
and in a city were you aware that
everybody that came up watched every
movement that you made I listen to
everything Edison yeah I had to make
sure that it didn't become so mechanical
that there wasn't a human contact
between me and everybody who came up
came up so I was I was very sensitive to
trying to make that eye contact saying
hello and thanking them really buy my
eye contact are saying hello for having
stood in line to to get a book and to
wait to have it signed it was very
pleasant moving experience to have so
many people come out to to see you to
get an autograph and to say hello is
there a moment or two that you remember
and all those people I read in this
journal you signed 60,000 one signature
2001 we did the last one in independent
bookstore in Norfolk late on a Friday
night nights at the end of week five and
I'll never forget one we did 60,000 I
said one more one more
60,000 and one I did I made 60,000 and
one as a symbol in the book and then
gave it to random house which they
spirited away somewhere my publisher I
better find out what they did with it I
mean for longer they're auctioning it
off for something there were there were
many moments a lot of a lot of old
friends showed up people I'd serve with
over the years a lot of my boyhood
friends came out in the Bronx one of the
prominent figures in the book from my
youth was a fella by the name of Ronnie
Brooks who was kind of my role model
when I was a young kid in college and
Ronnie died a few years ago but at the
book signing in New York suddenly there
appeared in front of me this wonderful
black lady who I hadn't seen in a number
of years frankly since his funeral it
was his mother who had said nothing had
tried not to get in there early but just
stood in line and waited to make see if
I would recognize when of course I did
and we all teared up and did some
hugging and kissing the some of some of
the young soldiers were in a helicopter
crash with me in Vietnam two of them
showed up one showed up with his whole
family it was very very touching and
lots of old friends showed up we've got
something here called an audio tape and
this is up for hours did Deb show that
on the screen did did you you I've
listened to it but it was just hard to
do it was it was hard to do it it it's
about a third of the book that's about
all you can get an audio tape it's
certainly not the whole book which
surprised me I thought I was gonna have
to do the whole book and was relieved
when I discovered that it was only about
a third of the book but it was it was
extracted down by professional people so
that you really are getting the essence
of the book when you listen to the audio
tape and it took about four days to do
and it's done under the most exacting
professional circumstances they had to
know what I had eaten that morning
make sure it wasn't syrupy so that when
I started speaking I didn't have any
sugar pieces in my mouth that would pop
I had to make sure that I didn't have
anything for breakfast that would cause
my stomach to Rumble because they could
hear it and anytime I made a mistake the
slightest mistake of pronunciation or
stumbling stop and we had to do it all
over again so it was essentially being
like an actor going for the Academy
Awards so that's those four hours took
about four days where'd you do it
through the studio in Washington do you
have any idea how well this is so no I
don't I haven't listened to it I've been
afraid to listen to it let's listen we
got a couple of exercises until 1:00 and
this is back to our Vietnam discussion
yes is the second tour 1968 and we'll
just listen to a minute or so and then
get your reaction to what it sounds like
okay Saturday afternoon November 16th we
had been flying west of Quang Ngai and
general Geddes uh-1h a top-of-the-line
helicopter the day before the 11th
infantry brigade had captured a large
cache of enemy weapons and documents
general Geddes wanted to see the
battalions prize and so we climbed
aboard a helicopter and headed for the
site we spotted the smoke grenades
signaling the site of the whole chopped
out of the heavy growth and headed for
it the pilot then began his descent
since I was sitting outboard I could see
how little clearance we had about two
feet at each end of the blade I began to
shout pull out but it was too late at a
height of about three stories the blade
struck a tree trunk one moment we were
flying and the next we were dead weight
I listened to the engines futile whine
for what seemed an eternity before we
smashed into the ground
standard procedure calls for getting
away from the aircraft as soon as
possible before it catches fire I
released my seat belt and jumped out the
door ahead of me was the helos gunner
private first class Bob Pyle
we did not get far from the wreckage
before we realized that the others were
still on board
none of them moving Pyle ran back to
Jimmy opened the pilots door I climb
back into the holes and found general
Geddes barely conscious I got him out
and dragged him away from the smoldering
helicopter by now several soldiers on
the ground had joined us as we went back
for the rest of the
victims in the end everyone was rescued
the most seriously injured being the
pilot who suffered a broken back
this hack of a day I'll never forget it
we were very very fortunate but I can
still remember the moment vividly of
looking out the door as we started down
into the jungle and I could see that the
pilot was not gonna be able to make the
clearance that was there and I remember
very vividly watching the blade hit the
tree whop and that was it I knew we were
going down and we dropped about three
stories are you 2 or 3 stories
what do you think of the auto tape
sounds pretty good well pleased his
first time I've heard it since I did it
Vietnam what is different in your life
what was different in your life after it
was all over and what's different in
this country because of the experience
the United States Army and those of us
who were the career leaders of the
United States Army we came out of
Vietnam with a lot of mixed emotions the
country had essentially said ok we want
to separate ourselves from this
experience we're not going to do this to
our young people again we're getting rid
of the draft we also picked up some of
the bad things that were happening in
our society at that time racial racial
divisions racial problems drug problems
in the United States Army and the other
services were not in good shape in the
early 70s as we came out of Vietnam and
those of us who were majors and
captain's and lieutenant Colonel's and
Colonels at that time said about the
task with the generals who were leading
us bill was Wesley Westmoreland many
others said about the task of rebuilding
the Armed Forces of the United States in
my case the army of the United States
and we had to restore a sense of pride
and who we were and what we did for the
nation it's a discipline a sense of
structure we had to go through what I
call the the coffeehouse period where
for a while we sort of said let's just
sit around with the troops and talk
about stuff and let's be buddies and
that we had to do some softening of the
army in order to stray
than it again and then we started to
reinstall standards and discipline and
this is what you do to be a good soldier
in the United States Army and we brought
that army back to the point where my
time Desert Storm came along or just
cause before Desert Storm our Panamanian
invasion the American people had a force
in the Army Navy Air Force Marine Corps
that they could be very proud of again
and one of the greatest achievements in
my life what I am very very happy about
and proud of is the fact that I was one
of those officers who stayed in after
Vietnam and was part of the rebuilding
effort me enormous warts cough and so
many many others whose names I can't
possibly list here today did the drug
culture come out of the war the drug
culture I think came out of society I
mean it was something that was happening
in our civilian society and the army is
a reflection of the society from which
it is drawn and so we got that from our
society I don't know that it was
probably made a little bit worse by
Vietnam but it really came out of
civilian society here in America and we
we went to work on drugs in the military
we tried counseling we tried soft
approaches and then finally we said it's
wrong you're not going to do it we will
help you if you have a problem if you do
not wish to be helped we will punish you
and will throw you out and we are deadly
serious about this so mandatory your
analysis testing and if you're in a
position of authority like a
noncommissioned officer or an officer
you're dead if if you indulge in any way
in drugs or if you tolerate it and we
essentially put in place a near zero
tolerance attitude within the military
and it's worked
did you read Robert McNamara's book yes
what'd you think of the book what do you
think of him I have very very mixed
emotions about the book I don't condemn
mr. McNamara no to I congratulate him I
think he's added to the body of
knowledge that we we have of Vietnam but
I can't help but think that if he felt
that strongly about it at that time and
he had such knowledge of it of the
failed situation we were in back in 68
or 69 I think he had an obligation to
speak up at that time
and he chose not to each others to
weighted number of years until coming
out with his book again go back to the
6263 era in Vietnam and the story of the
journalists how is pressure our press
relation is different today and and the
journalists that were there if you read
the Prochnow book where they're trying
to stop the war because they thought the
government was lying
is there a legacy and do you think they
were doing the right thing I think I
have never in all my years of public
life I have never blamed the press for
our failure in Vietnam or screamed at
the press because they did not handle
themselves properly during Vietnam they
reported what they saw they saw us doing
things that were not proper they saw us
creating statistics that were not
reflective of what was really going on
in the field it also went out of their
way sometimes to pain us in a bad light
it was it was a bad it was a bad scene
when I rose and rank and became senior
and I my other colleagues who have
served with in recent years we realized
we had to work with the press but at the
same time we also had to protect our own
secrets and we had to make sure that we
were doing what was right to the
American people so there should always
be something of an adversary
relationship I think that's good between
the press and the military realizing we
both have the same purpose and that's to
inform the American people on the
actions of their military leaders and
what's happening to their sons and
daughters in combat so I don't think
there's as much of Vietnam syndrome as
people claim at least it didn't it
didn't affect me particularly a free and
open press is something that is built
into our system and it is it is a
necessary check those have watched you
from the time you left the military
until the time this book came out so you
control your own public image pretty
closely I mean you wouldn't let us ever
bring a camera in any of your speeches
okay because imagine trolling my public
image I wanted to get off stage I mean I
was a private citizen
and I was writing a book and my
publisher wanted to make sure that I was
not giving away for nothing that was
with with my story which they had paid
me for to put in a book and so as part
of my contract arrangements I was not
doing in any any interviews because we
were waiting for my life story to be
reflected in the book and in the
speeches that I have given around the
country it's it's what I do for a living
and it's usually to private groups I've
given many other speeches that also
sometimes are covered or not schools
I've talked in prisons I revisit VA
hospitals I talk to young people and
I've been trying to essentially live a
more private life and then when the book
came out so much for a private life I
was back in public life giving
interviews everywhere at nauseam ad
infinitum and now that the book has been
promoted and I've made a decision with
respect to political life for the time
being I'm trying to recapture some of my
privacy again what did you think of the
experience the you know you could hear
people some of these talk shows get
madder and madder the more positive your
press was they thought the press was
trying to run you for president I can
show them evidence that there were some
members of the press who were less than
enchanted with with my possibility as a
politician but for the most part I've
had pretty good relations with the press
and I've had a pretty good press I think
is the term we would use for it and I've
always tried to be honest with the press
I try to give straight answers I try not
to dissemble but I really don't have a
stable of sources out there or people
that I am constantly calling and giving
stories to or somehow stroking myself
with I've just tried to be honest and
open and candid in my in my public
appearances and in my relationship with
the press but have you learned that you
can control your image if you want to
I've learned that you can take action
too you see when you use the word
control it's almost like you're
it's it's almost a synonym to spin your
image I think the best way to control
your image or to present yourself is to
always be as honest as you can as direct
as you can as candid as you can with the
members of the press who have their job
to do and you have your job to do I also
don't think it is necessary if you to be
constantly on camera all the time I I
don't I don't search for opportunities
to be on camera or to give interviews I
try to contain myself and keep some
privacy what about I've got the general
source code book here what about also
the criticism comes from some sectors
that you and general Schwarzkopf cashed
in you get a lot of money for speeches
and you get to write million-dollar
books and out of a public service well
both norm and I served in the United
States Army for 35 years when we retired
we became private citizens neither one
of us have done anything that has
brought any discredit upon our service
we have not gone into any kind of
defense business where we have used our
context and the contacts in the military
in any improper way what we essentially
are doing is appealing to the public for
you know or or going before the public
either in writing with books or speeches
and we it's a market system and I don't
find anything wrong with it at all
are you surprised that somebody would
pay you I don't know the reported $65 to
make a speech or the kind of money for
this book that the I assume that the
people who decided to buy the book for
what they bought it for and the people
who contract my for my services to speak
at various events believe they're
getting a good good service for the
amount of money they're paying for it
they seem to be satisfied and I seem to
be in some demand so I think it's I
think it's a it's a reasonable case of a
willing seller and a willing buyer
coming together to to produce a
a service or a product for the fire we
read a lot about your wife Alma when did
you meet her
I met Alma in 1961 in the fall of 1961
where is a blind date at the inn in
Boston Massachusetts when a friend of
mine asked me to accompany him to see a
young girl that he was interested in and
to I like to say pick off her roommate
or at least being of the double for a
roommate and her roommate turned out to
be Alma Johnson what was she like she
beautiful stunning beautiful intelligent
educated well-bred young lady and it
turned out to be a marvelous first
evening and that was it
how long before you got married or
engaged it was the next summer and we
were we were seeing each other and no
one else constantly but marriage had not
yet been discussed but then suddenly my
orders came to go to Vietnam and I was
going to leave for a year and as I tell
the story in the book
I said well will you write me and I'll
be back in a year and she essentially
said we are now 25 years old was a
little too little too late in our lives
to be quite that casual how how
important am I to you and I reflected on
that question and realized she was all
important to me and the next day I raced
back to her apartment and asked her to
marry me now there were some there was
some telephone calls and some knocks on
the door after that yeah she had some
lingering dangling boyfriend's around
the place we home I was not aware and
after we were married I moved into her
apartment they continued to show up and
so when there was a knock on the door
one Saturday afternoon and his very
charming young man was there with a box
of candy and I was relaxing you know day
off from the military and I had a
t-shirt on I don't think I had any shoes
on
no pants and I opened the door and there
he wasn't he looked me up and down and
he said who are you and I said I'm Colin
Powell and he said ones whatever his
name was I forgot his box of candy under
his arm and he said his Alma here since
yes she's here well can I see her and I
said sure so I invited him in and asked
him to sit in the living room oh I can
call them is this somebody or what this
wants to see you and she went out and
explained to this young man what my
status in the household now was and he
promptly left with his box of candy and
I kid a damn about it and because he had
identified himself as you know a very
close friend of hers and she has been
claiming for the last 33 years that that
was not the true nature of the
relationship I believe it was choice to
him what's she like she's a wonderful
woman an absolutely wonderful woman wife
mother lover my best friend and we've
had a fabulous marriage
what role does she play in your life I
mean how do you what's a day like she's
a central figure in my life
now that we are in retirement we spend a
lot more time with each other than we
ever did when I was in the military we
start the day together having breakfast
a cup of coffee and reading the
newspapers together after decades of me
blazing out of the house that's 5:30 in
the morning without spending any time
with her and we're usually together most
of the day she is in one part of the
house I'm in another part of the house
she lives very very and leads a very
very full and active life she's on the
board of the Kennedy Center here in
Washington she doesn't number of other
charitable things and she goes her way
and I go my way and we and then we get
together and go our way
but we're essentially together most of
the day it's wonderful at the end of
this book to her you obviously had some
decisions to make how did you do it the
end of the book tour I had to decide
what to do with the next phase of my
life 35 years as a soldier two years as
an author and now the
time to decide what next to do people
always many people saw it as he will
either go into politics or he will just
go away somewhere
but for me and for my friends and
advisors and for my wife there are more
choices in that go into politics go into
charitable work on educational
activities lots of things to do so I
always saw it as a broader set of
choices and just go into politics or not
but obviously because of a response to
the book tour everybody was waiting for
Powell to say something about making a
choice to run for the presidency of the
United States and I kept that option
open and it said to everybody I wanted
to keep that option open until I return
to public life and had a chance to see
what the book tour was like and then I
would make a decision and came home from
the book tour and then with some trusted
friends and advisers and I consulted
with a number of people but the end of
the day the real consultation was with
myself and with alman with our children
and after a period of about 10 days
roughly of most tense tense personal
reflections on our life and what this
would require we came to a conclusion
and I made a decision that this was this
was not the right thing for me to do or
for us to be how did you how was it
intense I mean how how did you do it
there was a great deal of pressure that
said you know you really should serve in
this way by running for political office
and what I eventually had to do was to
step back from all the external pressure
and all the encouragement and all the
enthusiasm I was getting from the
outside and I had to see whether I had
the internal enthusiasm and commitment
to go into what was going to be a very
very intense year and then what follows
from that year of political campaigning
something that I'm you know not that
familiar with even though I've been it
seated up close and it was going to be
very very demanding on me and on my
family
and I had to see if this is what Alma
wanted with the next phase of her life
we we've been a partnership for 33 years
but I've been sort of the dominant
partner because whenever the government
said whatever the army said move I just
went home and said Alan we're moving and
all she could do was say yes sir here we
go and we did that at almost two dozen
times in 33 years of marriage but in
this instance we had settled down and
she had things that she wanted to do in
her life and our children were out and
had things they were doing in their
lives and this choice to go into
politics would require a level of
commitment on their part in her part and
a level of exposure that we weren't just
worried we weren't ready for it this
time it's not that we feared that there
was something to be exposed that wasn't
the issue it's just that we wish to live
a more private life than we would be
able to live in in politics was there
ever a time in your discussions where
you decided you might do it and then
change your mind it went up and down for
a period of that whole period of 10 days
there are some times when I felt that I
think we this might be the right thing
for us to do and then we talked about it
some more and it would go down again it
was it was up and down it was the most
difficult decision I've ever had to make
because even though I knew I had to
separate myself from the enthusiasm of
encouragement for others I I've always
been a service person I've always tried
to serve the country and there were
large number of people who were
suggesting that this was the next form
of service for me and so I couldn't
ignore that and that would get me up but
then at the end of the day when I sat
with my families that was my wife my
closest friends and frankly just by
myself I was sure this was not the right
thing for me to do at this time your
wife never said things like I'll leave
you if you run for president you know
she never said that but it was clear
that this was not a choice she wished to
make what happens and I know you don't
like this scenario stay but what happens
if the nominee the Republican part
says I want you to be the vice president
I will stand on what I said at the press
conference last month I am NOT
interested in a political opportunity in
1996 and I'll stand on it the nice try
Brian should I try again no the the
thing in the in your book it's
interesting I went took your news
conference and there's a line same line
in your book and also in the news
conference about you know in the news
conference you say I did not yet have a
political eye because such a life
requires a calling that I do not yet
here and the same line is in the book
exactly did you go back and now make the
same liner ah when I when I wrote that
line in the book it was a late spring
early summer and when was the last time
that you wrote anything that is the last
word
the last comma in the book was the night
of the 3rd of July of of this year and
the neck that that night I called my
publisher and said tomorrow is July 4th
come get this thing right through 1995
1995 and the next morning somebody came
down on the on the shuttle from New York
I met her at the airport handed the
manuscript and said be gone and I never
touched it again until it was printed
and sought that was it so it was in late
spring early summer that I finished that
last chapter at last section you're
referring to the epilogue and said it
was a calling I do not get here but it
wasn't a new position for me to take I
mean I have been offered political jobs
as you noted from the book repeatedly in
the course of my military career why
don't you leave the army as an officer
and be the Undersecretary of the army
well when I was national security
advisor there was a suggestion that
perhaps I should think about politics at
that time no soldier and both parties
have approached me during the time that
I was in the army to suggest that after
the army politics may be the thing
and I never found it to be something
that connected with me because I'm
fundamentally a soldier now people call
me a political general but I'm
fundamentally a soldier that was my
ethic I had no political ambitions in
the course of my military career and I
did not feel a calling I knew who I was
as a soldier I trained all my life to
rise in the ranks of military and unique
skills are required for political life
I'm not ignorant of those skills and I'm
not ignorant of what it takes to be a
successful politician I work closely for
three presidents and I think I'm a
reasonably good politician I've had to
work with the Congress over the years
but at the point in my life when I had
to make this decision last month I did
not feel that it was the right thing for
me and I'm sure it was not the right
thing my family there's another line in
here I want to ask you because you did
change your mind on this bina this is on
page 607 because I expressed these
beliefs you're talking about
entrepreneurship and and free enterprise
system because I expressed these beliefs
some people have rushed rushed I'll be
paid to hang off Republican label around
my neck yeah they did but you decided
some point along the way hung it around
my own deck I I felt that I had seen
enough in the two years of my retirement
and I had been around the country and
these speeches that you referred to
earlier I I learned a lot of things
about what was happening in the country
a lot of people and I felt I should get
off the fence now that I'm no longer
protected by my uniform from being
partisan anyway I thought I should get
off the fence and start to actively
participate in the political life of the
country as a private citizen and I
thought I could best do that as a
Republican so I have identified myself
and I am now a member of the Republican
Party how you doing with so you want
I mean you suggested at your news
conference that she shade it we haven't
discussed this I don't know where she
will end up I'm gonna not speak for her
what about the kids but there are the
kids the kids are ok my son is a
Republican he is all
he is worked in Republican circles
previously he became a Republican before
I became a Republican what's he do now
he is a lawyer here in town fermer from
Elba Nate Meyers and he's a he's a very
fine lawyer and the two girls my two
daughters they have not told me what
their political affiliation is I'm not
sure they have decided wouldn't bet on
them being Republicans one is an actress
and the other one works at ABC Nightline
she only works Anne Marie Ann Marie
works for Ted Koppel and Nightline and
Linda is the other Linda's a very very
accomplished actress she's appearing in
Baltimore now and she'll be coming to
Arena Stage here in Washington shortly
speaking of acting in this audiotape
there were moments where you were a
little more dramatic in others and I
want to play one for you this is a story
you've told before let's listen to this
and get your reaction to this part of
the tape on a speech circuit I tell a
story that goes to the heart of
America's longing the ABC correspondent
Sam Donaldson was interviewing a young
african-american soldier in a tank
platoon on the eve of battle and Desert
Storm Donaldson asked how do you think
the battle will go
are you afraid we will do okay we're
well trained and I'm not afraid the G I
answered gesturing toward his buddies
around him
I'm not afraid because I'm with my
family the other soldiers shouted tell
him again he didn't hear you
souls are repeated this is my family and
we'll take care of each other that story
never fails to touch me or the audience
it is a metaphor for what we have to do
as a nation we have to start thinking of
America as a family we have to stop
screeching at each other stop hurting
each other and instead start caring for
sacrificing for and sharing with each
other there's more what do you think of
the drama there well it's it's my
favorite story I've told us hundreds of
times
and I use it in my my speech around the
country and always touched by it's a
wonderful piece of television that Sam
Donaldson did on the audiotape I gussied
it up a little bit but the audiotape was
designed to be somebody sitting in a car
with you talking to you you're not
supposed to be watching a mini drama
just remember that you're driving along
in a car with somebody telling him this
story but look back on that on the whole
book to earth all the interviews what do
you think of the xperia what would you
tell somebody that was about to do this
what did you learn from it I found it
very very enjoyable but very very
exhausting I had talked to other authors
out
I would tell folks that one of the sad
things about it is if you're expecting a
large crowd only thing you can do is
your signature
regrettably you can't say to aunt Minnie
and uncle Ezra I would say make
eye-contact and show some human response
to everybody who goes through the line I
would say make sure you well-rested and
enjoy the experience it I I don't know
most authors do not go out for five
weeks it's usually a much shorter tour
and it's it's seldom as many as 25
cities but it can be done and I had a
good time on it I also went to two
countries during that five-week period I
went to England I went to France what
about the media part of it the
interviews the interviews I found those
to be very interesting and the what I
haven't done a lot of is radio and on
this tour I got a chance to do a lot of
radio and I found that to be very very
interesting and enjoyable because you
usually had enough time to develop a
theme on a radio and it isn't it isn't
quite as demanding as television you
didn't have to be as OnPoint as I think
you have to be on television and so I
got a lot of radio experience but I
found it most enjoyable on the cover of
this book is your photo as taken by
Annie Leibovitz famous photographer name
is pathar
what do you think of that idea Annie has
photographed me before she did a Vanity
Fair shot of me right after the Gulf War
so I was pleased that she was available
to to do this shot working with her is
great because she is an absolute
professional we did it in a in a library
here in Washington she took lots of
shots of me in uniform and civilian
clothes we even have a Larry King in
suspenders kind of shot but of all the
shots that's the one that we selected
that's the one I published we thought it
was best
this seems out of context but in the
book you referred to reading street
without joy by Barnard fall Frenchman
died back during the Vietnam War as
quickly as well why'd you read that and
what impact today at that time in the
early 60s when we were trying to learn
about Vietnam Barnard fall was
considered one of the great experts on
the country because he had Chronicle the
French experience in French Indochina in
Vietnam and so we all read Barnard fall
as part of our training streak without
joy was the story of route 1 the main
artery going up South Vietnam that the
French had such difficulty along and we
probably all should have studied Bernard
fall a lot longer and was greater
intensity especially people in high
policy positions because he made it
clear in that book and we should have
realized that that it was war as much
about nationalism and self-determination
within this one country than it was
about the ideology of communism or the
worldwide communist conspiracy reading I
bring it up is the what I want to ask
you the general question about books how
often have books have had an impact and
you mention a lot of books in there yeah
I read a great deal I haven't read as
many books as I would like to in recent
years because when you chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff you're reading
things from 7 o'clock in the morning
when the intelligence folks show up
until late that night and it's difficult
to get into novels or into biographies
or historical books but them I'm getting
back in the swing of things now
reading a few things that are strictly
for fun and for my general rounding as
opposed to work when you in the book you
say and we've talked about this in other
interviews about your that you call it a
turning point in your life when you were
selected for the White House Fellows
program why do you think you were
selected and why do you think is a
turning point I think I was selected
because I was doing rather well in my
career as a military officer
it's a very intense interview process
you have to go through go through and I
think I interviewed well with the people
who were who were selecting fellows that
year I was a little more mature than the
other fellows it was it was an age limit
at that time before it became
discriminatory to have age limits and I
was at the upper edge of the age limit
and the people who were doing the
panel's that year saw something in me
that they found attractive and thought
it useful to pick me and give me this
experience it was a turning point
because until then I was just your
average army officer going along through
life learning how to be a better
infantry officer and suddenly I went
from being just your average army
officer to somebody who was working in
the White House meeting presidents
working in the Office of Management and
Budget examining the whole federal
government getting exposed to the whole
federal government seeing how Congress
works seeing how policy is being made at
the highest levels of of the government
and then after a year of this suddenly
I'm back to being an infantry officer I
was shipped off to Korea to command a
battalion but that experience of seeing
government at that level stayed with me
so that about five or six years later
when I am now a brigadier general the
gentleman who I had met in my White
House fellows year at OMB cap Weinberger
and Frank Carlucci come back into my
life remember me and I go to work for
them and was able to use the high-level
government experiences that I had had
years earlier as White House Fellow so
it really fundamentally changed the
shape of my career in the shape of my
life after you discuss in the book a lot
of Republicans and the
the Weinberger's in people like that you
do make this statement at the end that
you and President Clinton were close
would you mean by that we got along very
very well we obviously had differences
on some issues gays and lesbians in the
military but as a personal matter we got
along very very well we do to this day
even though I have I have gone on to
become a Republican we talking the phone
from time to time and we have very very
cordial discussions and I like President
Clinton and one we wouldn't be first
started working together at the
beginning of his administration and we
had this very difficult issue of whether
or not to allow gays and lesbians in the
military and I said to him after one of
the meetings first meeting on the
subject I said mr. president I'm very
very sorry that this had to be the first
issue that you had to deal with what the
military I hoped it would be something
else and I regret that this is the case
and what he said to me was I understand
that Colin and but you know this is a
very tough issue it was easy somebody
would have solved it before we came
along so we will just work this problem
and that that showed understanding for
the problem that those of us in the
military had with this issue at that
time and still do and we he and I were
able to work every issue that we faced
in that in that same way problems to be
dealt with I spent a lot of quiet
private time with President Clinton
usually when I went to see him we would
meet alone one on one with no one else
for long periods of time so I think I
have a good relationship with President
Clinton even though I'm sure we will
have areas of disagreement in the future
as we've had in the past on various
things I'm going to try one more time on
something I know you're going to smile
up what is your hunch about your future
you think it think you'll ever find
yourself out there shaking hands saying
vote for me anytime I can't I can't
answer that
and I won't I won't try to one of the
things I did learn along the way is
don't
trapped into trying to answer
hypothetical questions about the future
the beauty of my personal situation and
and the wonderful thing about the
country we live in is that there are all
kinds of opportunities out there there
are all sorts of doors that are that are
waiting to be open I would hope that my
my future life will be one of service to
society in one way or another I'm not
sure how best to perform that service is
there anything about the Republic being
a Republican that you don't like I have
I have said candidly that I think there
are some aspects of a Republican
political activity right now that are
they're a little too harsh I think we're
a Republican Party as a party is coming
down a little too harshly on affirmative
action it isn't all bad it isn't all
preferences and quotas very very good
things have happened with good
affirmative action over the last thirty
years and I think we have to be careful
as we get rid of things that no longer
make sense like quotas and and
preferences that are no longer based on
anything we can't show such a harshness
to the affirmative action that has
produced such good things over the years
that we communicate the wrong signal to
people who are still in need of
affirmative action and I've criticized
my party for that I also think we have
to be very very careful as we change the
social safety net system as we change
welfare reform and Medicaid and Medicare
things that do need change and the
Democrats are going to change as well we
have to remember that at the at the far
end of this process there are there are
young people and in many cases there are
young people who have only one parent at
home who are in need and if we don't
make sure that they are provided for in
some way that we better start building
all the jails we're going to need for
them in 18 years when when the call
comes from the people running for the
sent in the house for you to come speak
for them you're going to do it some of
the calls have started to come in
already at the moment I have elected not
to do any active campaigning or
political fundraising I am a private
citizen who happens to be a Republican
and here is the book of the private
citizen called
my American Journey Colin Powell with
Joseph II Persico thank you for joining
us thank you very much Brian